combien de journées d'un jour 3 le
premier vainqueur
la première actes et leur famille durant
une heure
je ne suis pas couché perriand
maintenant que c'est des gens tout le
bois qu'ils ont là il faut travailler le
pain cependant le manque en fait du pain
il ya des fois la cathine qui parle de
télé à aux postulants au fond du chiffre
au gala non il faut travailler son pain
est un bon feeling et pas de la pilule
n'est pas de la poudre
honnêtement il faut le poignet ouais
c'est le point qu'il faut un pif aux
abois du gouffre sans fin pour l'amour
de son travail mais maintenant ils ont
pu sont en finale que susan galiero la
pensée des hommes ont peu fait louis
roumégas sont quand même à bahia la
voilà c'est votre magasin ici même le
sage c'est ma cuisine c'est la même
chose c'est me dépanne magasin les
clients soient mes clients ici ou quand
je suis occupé du matin à la boulangerie
pourquoi on n'est pas que je ne veux pas
payer sa beauté racée faudrait payer des
impôts à l'état l'âge vous payez et puis
c'est plus sympathique de la wii ah ben
oui merci waâda même si le oui c'est une
bonne cliente louis ne peut rester avec
nous deux minutes là vous êtes tous les
jours pourquoi vous avez ici parce que
son mari y est conseillé en jouant mal
oui mais c'est pas une raison pour les
moyens qu'il dockers avant voilà ce que
vous pensez du pain de message ni bons
ni bien cuit au bois et du bon pain j'ai
des bons clients pour moi très bon
client analyse agnès mois bel air
parce que on boit le coup en même temps
il s'est mis alors on vient prendre son
pain et en même temps mais bien l'oeil
apporte une bouteille
le tpo talopp et moi j'appelle un
couteau
alors ça vous coûte cher alors de votre
pas finalement moi je ne paie pas
toujours à bon bon chacun son tour voilà
il ya d'autres boulangers dans le pays
c'est oui à me faire pilule alli alli la
pilule
macha allah la poudre ni attirer les
meilleurs
oui parfaitement
c'est mon métier et j'espérais de
contenus inconvenants mon métier parce
que vous auriez l'âge de prendre la
retraite maintenant longtemps il ya cinq
ans j'ai ma retraite ne nous sommes pas
fait assez pour l'athlète nos hôtes
comme artisan et même si vous aviez de
l'argent est-ce que vous arriveriez de
faire le pont
enfin c'est ça non je ne serai pas
invité si j'arrêtais ce cimetière et je
ne veux pas aller au cimetière
maintenant je suis encore jeune j'ai
bien envie de vous acheter un pas moi
oui vont m'entendre dire à paris son
bail aujourd'hui affectée par quoi passe
comment est faite de bouteilles
[Musique]